e
ses quatres médecins.un médecine
comme on trouve dans bien
des régions du Québec.
Louis Duquette a 69 ans
et pratique à Saint-Patrice
Comme biComme biComme biComme bs
de sa génération, il part
bientôt à la retraite,
mais il ne trouve personne pour
le rempl
- Jocelin, c'est moi!
- Il suit plusieurs patients
depuis des décennies,
comme Joscelin Camiré.
- Il a secouru Joscelin en 1995l
qui l'a paralysé.
- Lâchdeux coups. T'es un champ.
- Et soiurs
générations de la même famille.
JOSCELIN CAMIRÉ, patient
du Dr Louis Duquette
- Mes grands parents étaient
avec eux autres au village.
nous autres, ma soeur,
ses enfants.
- Avec la retraite du
Dr Duquette, plusieux risqeux rr
sans médecin.
- Bien, combien de patients
que vous aviez toi et Claire?
il en reste 3000.
atients pourraient
devenir orphelins à la
Coopérative de sannière. Parce ,
le Dr Duquette n'est pas le seul
à vouloir prendre sa retraite.
- Là, elle es-tu à 36 semaines?
- Claire Nantel a 69 ans et
pratique elle aussi ici depuis
sa retraite.
- Il est à 146,
c'est bien correct.
- Dre Nantel a encores faute
de relève médicale, elle ne peut
garantir à cette jeune maman
qu'un médecin va pouvoir
Dre CLAIRE NANTEL, médecin,
Coop de santé, sudière
- Elle devrait le prendre,
ton bébé.
- Là, toi je le sais pas.
- Une nouvelle qu'elle doit
annoncer à tous ses patients.
me dit : "Qu'est-ce que je vais
faire, docteure? Que
je vais faire, docteure?
Allez-vous m'en trouver un,
au coeur. C'est sûr que ça rend
notre... notre marche versle.
- Dans la salle à côté,
même scénario.
- Bon matin.
- Pas deGrégoire Simard, qui est
pourtant sur le point
d'accoucher.
- J'ai des gens qui viennent
"Oui, mais moi, Louis,tu me con.
Tu me laisseras pas de même?"
C'est dé Tu m'avais dit que
t'attendais...
- Le 20 avril.
- Dans la région, le départ
des deux médecins suscite
beaucoup d'inquiétude.ISABELISAé
du sud de Lotbinière
- Les gens viennent ici
en clinique, disent :
"Qu'est-vais faire
si je n'ai plus de médecin?"
Oui, vous allez pouvoir venir.
Mais présentement, on est
quatre. On en a deux qui
partent. Les sans rendez-vous
vont être pleins.
Ça va déborder!
- Le départ de ces médecins âgés
qui suivent beaucoents
est un problème partout
au Québec. En 2017, 145 médecins
ont pris leur retraite au
Québec. Un nombre qui est passé
à 275 lr. Le problème
préoccupe le Collège des
médecins du Québec, qui souhaite
que les médecins apprennent
à délége tâches
aux autres professions.
Dr MAURIL GAUDREAULT, président,
Collège des médecins du Québec
- Travailler avec d'autres
la santé
de façon proche et intime,
pendant leur cours de médecine,
ils sont pas tant que ça mis en
situation d'interdisciplinarité.
s à mon avis, c'est là
qu'il faut travailler plus que
de chercher à former un plus
grand nombre de médecins.
- Il a passé un TACO pulmonairee
déjà avec l'infirmière
Linda Blondeau. Il souhaiterait
en avoir deux autres, mais là
aussi, c
Il n'y a pas de solution
facile. Surtout pas, pour
le Dr Duquette, d'imposer
des quotas aux jeunes médecins.
- Là, puis on fait...
On transfère ça comme
des chiffres anonymes.
Il faut que tu en prennes
1000, il faut que tu en prennes
1500. Ça marche pas de même,
la médecine. Il y a une relation
qui s'établit, ça prend
du temps, ça.
- Mais ici le temps presse.
Faute de médecins, l'avenir
de la clinique est compromise.-,
l'année prochaine, on va
quitter. Si on laisse la
clinique telle qu'elle est là,é.
- Ici Davide Gentile,
Radio-Canada, Mo